one of the ways that you bonded was
through martial arts and you all train
together
you've obviously I mean you've played
Muhammad Ali's so you've been in many
roles where you've had to be very
physical you've been down this road
before but you all had to train pretty
seriously is that true yeah David takes
that really really seriously you know
David is you know one of the best
directors that I've ever worked with
I mean he a little crazy he'll go crazy
but you can't take that away from him
you know to me right it's like David he
knows how to get inside of a human mind
you know and like stir it all up and
they say action you know could you think
you're bonding and you're being friends
and you're telling them all your darkest
secrets and we're all spending time
together you know and when you start
telling our secrets and we're opening up
and then Dave is like yeah yeah yeah and
then one day on the set he's like yo
dude she's their girl - cheated on you
in eighth grade
[Laughter]
[Applause]
way you guys bonded over music - is that
right I mean musics important to you is
important you like the cast to listen to
ya a certain song yeah I gave new me
some music to listen to and I think I
gave you some stuff and yeah it just it
just I mean there's real soul to music
and yeah and what a direct you know
there'll be songs or a playlist I kind
of listened to you that gets me inspired
what what's what's give me an example of
a song that you guys bonded over that
was really out there hmm well so the
songs I was playing with my didn't I had
this song I love this song called heels
on and I was playing it kind of in my
corner of the makeup trailer a lot like
kind of quite low because it's quite
sexual it's like Jamaican it's a it's a
beautiful like black woman singing she's
called Lady Saw and it's very full on so
I was like one day it was like what is
it heels on just try act like I don't
know what are you talking about so like
yeah so one days will was like can you
turn it up and I was like should i and
then it's like she sings like I'm gonna
hear with my heel saw and I'm
yeah
newbies playlist new new me listens to
rap music dead black people be like nah
nah turn that hour for ya nope be like
nah we can't listen to that
you